Buenos días Pues como ustedes pueden ver
son varios cientos de personas que están
llegando aquí a la Plaza de la bastillas
desde aquí desde donde partirá esta
manifestación el día de hoy que
terminará en la Plaza de la ópera Se
esperan entre unas 600 mil a 800.000
personas que manifesten el día de hoy
Esto en todo el país según cifras de las
autoridades eso es una cifra muy por
debajo del manifestaciones anteriores
pero como usted bien lo decía Esta es
una manifestación justo después de que
ya está reforma hubiera sido adoptada
este pasado lunes después de ese voto de
la moción de censura hay también
muchísima presencia de de policía
incluso hasta dos horas antes de que
comience esta manifestación alrededor de
toda esta zona muchísima policía
muchísima gendarmería son cerca de
12.000 efectivos de policía y gendarmes
que van a estar en todo el país cien mil
solamente aquí en la capital en donde
bien puede presentarse disturbios a lo
largo de toda esta manifestación
Natalia cómo están los ánimos entre los
manifestantes después de la entrevista
de este miércoles concedida por macron
Bueno ese es uno de los puntos más
importantes a ver qué es lo que piensan
los franceses después de esa
intervención de la presidente la mayoría
de ellos de hecho hablé con muchos de
ellos decían no la vimos porque la hizo
a la una de la tarde hora local cuando
todo el mundo está o trabajando o
almorzando muchos de ellos dijeron que
incluso no les había interesado prender
el televisor para poder ver lo que él
decía Pero hablé con dos señoras una que
trabaja en una funeraria y venía a esta
manifestación con su amiga que trabaja
en la total Ese es el gigante energético
francés y ambas me explicaban que para
una de ellas incluso Es la primera vez
que sale a manifestar en toda su vida
que consideran que están en contra de
esta reforma porque sí trabajar dos años
más implica Pues un mayor esfuerzo a
pesar de que no tengan un trabajo duro
digamos no que sea muy demandante
Físicamente pero sobre todo lo que me
han podido decir estas personas así como
varias de también de las pancartas que
se ven que están teniendo aquí los
manifestantes es que están sobre todo en
contra del método utilizado por el
gobierno para que pasar esta reforma es
decir el artículo 49-3 de la
Constitución ese esa herramienta
constitucional que le permitió al
gobierno de Manuel Macao y de la primera
ministra Elizabeth de hacer que esta
reforma pues fuera aprobada por decreto
sin necesidad del voto de la asamblea y
estas personas nos decían nosotros
votamos por diputados para que nos
representen y para que voten por
nuestros intereses y finalmente el
gobierno ha impedido que esto ocurra Así
que estos son los ánimos en mucha rabia
por parte de los franceses por ese
método por esa manera un poco violenta
me decían en la que el gobierno había
hecho adoptar esta reforma